assalamualaikum everybody greens of
Peace the headlines are reading all over
Irish singer Sinead O'Connor if you
haven't heard the sad news has died at
the age of 56 causes of death are
unknown at this time may God Almighty
Allah the Creator have mercy on her and
Grant her Jannah but we do begin with
that breaking news from the Music World
ABC News is learning that Irish singer
Sinead O'Connor has died at the age of
56. many news agencies are reporting on
this breaking news covering different
portions in her life what made her
famous the early portions of her life
some of the controversies like her
tearing up the picture of the Pope
because she was protesting the abuse and
the scandals in the church regarding the
children that later came to the
mainstream I also went through some of
these report to see how much time they
gave if any to the greatest decision
that she made in her life was a few
years back before she died accepting
Islam now at the time this was huge news
they're not really giving too much focus
on it I'd like to hear what you guys
have to say what do you have to say
about that leave it in the comments
below but for those of you who want to
know I was fortunate enough I was
blessed to go ahead and speak to Sinead
O'Connor off camera and on camera she
made a promise that she would only talk
to me and also I made a promise that I
would only talk to you
that when I was ready to talk about it I
would only talk to you when she was
ready to talk shortly after she accepted
Islam and Sinead O'Connor she kept her
promise and we had an historic
exclusive interview so I thought this
would be a great opportunity for those
who have not seen the interview who are
really curious to know towards the end
of her life before her death why would
Sinead O'Connor she was a legend in her
era Irish icon somebody who was like an
Elvis Presley of her time very famous
well-known she ends up accepting Islam
they're not touching upon it too much so
for the reporters out there for the news
agencies they can also watch this
interview that we did if they want to be
fair and balanced they can go ahead and
report also
on many of the things that she discussed
she gives some very intelligent answers
to the questions that I've asked her
and you guys can go ahead and benefit
from this interview
she really really went against the odds
and she was bold and fearless and
accepting Islam why that's the question
well you're only gonna find out truly
because this was the one of the only
interviews
that happen out there the first
so we made history with this
alhamdulillah
and going deep into her story here on
the dean show so I hope you enjoy and
hopefully this can be a benefit to open
your heart open your mind and enjoy this
interview I did with Sinead O'Connor and
at the end I'm going to have a special
gift
for you there's no introduction needed
uh we're with Sinead O'Connor one of the
Legends out there you you um actually
made a statement and it's a really
profound but first before that I want to
say that you you purposely didn't want
to do any interviews because you didn't
want people questioning your sincerity
in this decision of becoming a Muslim
no uh it was more because I felt that I
didn't want to have to
a it was it was a private decision yeah
um B I didn't want to I didn't enjoy
um privately having to justify it to
people yeah there's so much there's so
much stigma you know and I felt like you
know what I don't have to explain to you
or to anybody else why I became a Muslim
yeah and that so that's what I was
trying to avoid I didn't feel like I had
to explain it to anybody you know do you
know I also very good advice which from
you know someone whose name I'm I
promise not to mention but a prominent
musician who also became a Muslim
advised me that the best thing I could
do would be to keep as quiet as possible
you know so I made a promise to myself
that for a certain length of time I
would not go to the mosque for example
because I didn't want media following me
there yeah I'm bringing all of that
there and also I made a promise that I
would only talk to you
that when I was ready to talk about it I
would only talk to you so I'm not after
this I'm not talking about it you know
although saying in saying that I know
that can't be true a because I'm female
and I love talking and
I feel so passionately about Islam and
and and passionately about defending it
against stigma that I probably will talk
a lot about it but I wasn't ready you
know well thank you so much thank you
for coming on The Dean show is it do you
do you find it ironic that people can
make all different personal decisions in
life and they won't catch as much heat
they'll do all sorts of things and now
why when it comes to Islam now it's like
everybody's uh you know just going
bizarre well you know you know why it's
because the very tenant tenants of Islam
are against everything the world
worships the world worships money that
Islam is the truth that has the truth
and has the truths plural and that's why
it's so dangerous our culture is built
on one great big lie which is that Jesus
Christ was the son of God right and all
the ensuing lies that can be manipulated
out of that including the very idea that
Constantine had some type of epiphany
sure he did he wanted to exploit
something and cause a whole series of
lives and that's what happened Islam has
the truth the person who has the truth
and who also um has nothing to lose is
an extremely dangerous person you know
and that's how Islam is perceived in in
Ireland also we suffered from the same
stigma also because of extremists that
we also had extremists because we had a
war going on here and there was a
Prejudiced and false idea that if you
stood up at all for Irish nationalism
this meant that you supported terrorism
you know and I think that you're falsely
admend that you know and I think that
Islam has suffered from the same stigma
that because there are extremists and
there are terrorists it's very easy for
those who want to stigmatize us to say
that we're all terrorists and we all
support terrorism which of course we
don't you know yes
um so and then I found it what I was
amazed by was the Prejudice I found from
women about the fact that I choose to
wear a hijab
um because I find it amusing because to
me they're saying to me that oh you're
trying to
um comply with Eastern man's view of
beauty first of all I'm not look at the
stage of me I'm not beautiful at all but
secondly it's nothing to do with that
it's a choice and in fact under the
under the
Islamic law my at my age I don't have to
wear a hijab actually you know but what
amuses me about it is that these women
have their hair bleach blonde it's got a
thing going across here and it goes down
here their hair their hair itself is a
hijab their very hair they're trying to
conform in fact a western men's idea of
beauty so I keep saying well if you
don't like hijab then shave your hair
because it's the same thing there's no
difference you know so but I'm amazed at
the Prejudice about that I found more
Prejudice by wearing the hijab than
about actually becoming Muslim you know
and like so consequently I love wearing
it you know and I I feel naked without
it you know uh people I mean you pretty
much to some it up you said by saying
the the shahada uh by accepting Islam is
that you love the creator of the heavens
and earth first and foremost Beyond
materialism beyond anything in creation
you did what Jesus did you did what
Moses and all these great Messengers
that God Almighty sent that's all you're
doing in essence you're just choosing to
love and put God Almighty first saying
I'm not going to work for anything but
the crater that's Islam that's what
Islam is what happened to me was I had
been studying theology since I was seven
years of age really in truth and I'd
gone to college and I had studied all
different kind of things and I had left
Islam to last for some reason probably
because I had Prejudice you know
um and then what happened was and only
yesterday in the Quran did I hear it
being said that that this would happen
to people what happened to me was as
soon as I started to read it and listen
to it I realized oh my god I've been a
Muslim all my life and I didn't know it
oh wow yeah I was all my life because
it's a headspace it's a way of thinking
Islam is a way of thinking about God
that's exactly what you just said
somebody who believes that nothing in
this world should be worshiped more than
God even though I fail sometimes I'm not
perfect I fail I worry about money I
worry about the things that we all worry
about I forget sometimes that I don't
need to do that do you know what I mean
in fact I forget look you know and you
know so yeah that's what happened to me
what if you say why did you become why
did you decide to revert revert is the
right word yes I was always always a
Muslim and I didn't even know you know
yeah that's that's the belief that every
child is born in a natural state if you
left it alone it would worship just the
Creator the one God Alone yeah yeah
and that's what you did you came back to
the Natural Way you came back to the
pure way of pure monotheism worshiping
only the one God
it's very much for me about the strength
of the scriptures the intelligence the
sheer intelligence of the scriptures
that I just knew immediately like nobody
wrote this book God nobody signed this
to Gabriel or tomorrow but God nobody
could have created it but God is so
intelligent and so you know it's
mind-blowing I can't even find words
it's mind-blowing and every time I
listen to it I'm more mind blown and you
know what I love as well which is
probably I shouldn't of but I do
um some of the insults Irish people love
insults and I love them when God gets
annoyed in in the Quran when Allah says
things like um we will round him upon
the snout you know and things like that
when God is in the temperate it's kind
of funny some of it and I love so much
what he says um you know if there were
two gods in the sky you would have
ruined both of them yeah you know and
that talks about the religion that I
left the religion you're born into which
is Catholicism you know that that to me
sums up Catholicism there were as they
believe more two Gods which is the devil
is there another God then they will
destroy both of them you know yes so
that's the culture that I've I've had
the honor to leave behind I've done that
that religion of Lies
[Music]
now now the the Irish people have a
really good history uh with the Muslims
I I remember the Potato Famine at one
point when you had this Potato Famine
and then the Muslims came and you know
lent support and and the Irish have
really been loyal to that and they they
respected that that you know that help
and and the Irish are really amazing uh
people uh we have our the second largest
uh minority if you like or majority in
this country is Islamic people is
Muslims so we have a huge Muslim culture
now you know but it's not big enough
because there's not enough mosques you
know there need to be more moths but
still the the we we are now thank God we
used when I was growing up it was only
Catholicism here but in this country now
there are many different religions but
after Catholicism the strongest and most
fastest growing religion in this country
is Islam is Islam huh yes and so the
course of Catholic Church are terrified
of Islam come on I mean it's a
no-brainer and they have every reason to
be terrified and you know if it was if
Islam is good enough for Muhammad Ali
it's good enough for me it's good for
anybody else anybody but it's good
enough for Muhammad Ali it's a very
frightening to cover the church for many
reasons I can explain that for an hour
but I think you'd understand what I'm
saying yeah maybe you can because you
were you were the the person that Conor
McGregor picked out of everyone to come
out for his opening song Maybe now you
can actually get help get some dawah and
invite him to this to the purpose of
life you know maybe you can get him now
like he invited you you can invite him
for a sit down and talk to Conor
McGregor yeah but you know what I really
believe is that you know in the
scripture where it says you know take me
by the forelock and make Islam the limit
of my desire
you know
Allah will take who he wants yeah
but like actually Wells yes precisely I
don't feel like it's my job to convert
anything no no that's none of it our job
is just to to be the best human beings
we can and to convey yeah you know to
try to do our best to compare yeah yeah
I don't know because I really do feel I
love that part of the scripture that
this idea of of Allah taking you by the
forelock and Britain you need to Islam
if you know and you won't you won't
understand the Quran or understand Islam
at all if it isn't already injured you
know I'm saying nobody can put that in
you yeah
how was it also we we when Lindsay Lohan
do you know her when she started reading
the Quran you know she she's she's
trying to you know get her life together
and then as soon as the whiff got around
that she was reading the Quran she also
caught some heat did you ever talk to
her or me realize until after I
converted that she had done the same I
saw an article about it so I didn't I
didn't realize she had done that at all
but I was delighted to know yeah I don't
know her I never met her anymore
so you made a You made a statement it
was very powerful uh uh proud to have
become Muslim the natural conclusion of
any intellectual so any intellectual
theologian's journey I mean that's such
a profound statement I mean this is not
something that's hard to figure out one
God worship him alone simple easy to
understand
and also you know no Theologian as far
as I'm concerned has the right to call
themselves a theologian if they have not
studied the Quran that they have deeply
listened and I don't mean read it
because it's not for reading as such you
know to me I don't get it when I just
look at it with my eyes I have to hear
the way it was designed to be
hard you know yeah and then but you
can't say your theology Theologian if
you haven't studied Islam as far as I'm
concerned and if you study to let Islam
and say you're a theologian and come out
trying to crucify Islam then you're not
a theologian either because you don't
have the intelligence only only of an
intelligent Theologian can hear the
Quran and go
I'm home that's home do you know yes you
are how is it now because you you almost
like conquered the world I mean what I
mean by that is that you you had
everything that this world can offer
right and and many people are still
chasing that they feel like if I just
make a hit record if I just make you
know a little more more money you know
how does it compare because you've been
all that and what advice do you have for
people who they don't you know take it
to the next level they just you know
succumb to their desires and just want
to chase material the material things
but they forget about connecting with
the one who created them well you know
I'm no different I'm the same as every
other human being we all do that
we all do that we're all flawed on no
different as I said here earlier on I
worry about money you know I'm not as
rich as people might think I am you know
32 years ago I had one hit records you
know what I'm saying I had to work to
make my money same as anyone else I'm
not broke and I'm not a poverty do you
know what I mean but yeah you know I
worry about the same things I forget
sometimes as I've told you earlier to to
remember that I don't need to worry you
know yeah yeah so I don't feel like I'm
in a position to advise any person who
is suffering because you know I would
advise that people obviously to hear the
Quran and to believe I know I'm talking
to myself even when I say this to
believe that there's no reason to assume
that God has been God has always taken
care of me so I have no reason to assume
he will continue to take care of me but
you know I suppose it's very hard you
can't from a position of feeling okay
lecture people who are not okay you know
what I'm saying I understand yeah
sometimes Faith doesn't put food in your
mouth you know that's the fact the fact
is there are an awful lot of people in
the world as we were talking we were
dying of starvation even though they're
the most faithful people on Earth you
know and I can't advise those people who
they should feel are you know what I
mean yeah how how do you uh have some
people come around I mean now from the
shock have some friends or family like
after they've has anyone taken the
initiative to be like hold on let me
open this Quran up let me actually see
for myself instead of hearsay
um well the people close to me were very
good to me about it actually and um the
person who has become interested is my
father he is a very religious person
your father my father is very religious
person and he is very interested in it I
have a hobby which is painting
scriptures I've always painted
scriptures and I made him recently um
the scripture that says not a leaf falls
but he knows it Allah
I gave that to him for Father's Day and
he loved it so he said that he would
like to start to read the Quran but I
keep saying to people no don't read it
listen to it you have to it's not
designed for reading Maha couldn't read
as it said in the prophet Isaiah right
is predicted in Isaiah saying he's going
to be illiterate he can't depressed
that's actually a prophecy prophesied in
the last and final mention of prophet
Muhammad yeah in the book of Isaiah 29
chapter 29 yeah and so it's not so I
keep saying to people no please don't
read it it's not for reading it's for
listening to Muhammad don't you think he
must have been a beautiful singer he
must have a beautiful voice you know to
recite the Quran to be the first person
chosen by God to recite the Quran he
must have had some voice you know it's
just amazing goes beyond uh
comprehension that a man who was
illiterate he he he couldn't read or
write someone who was known as being the
the the trustworthy to be able to
compile a book today that's memorized by
millions I mean all over the world and
and sometimes even if a person can't
understand uh what's being said but they
hear the Quran is powerful it's very
very powerful yeah I find it much more
powerful to hear like if you look at how
it was created it was designed for the
ear
music I mean it's it's I know that this
is not PC to call it singing because it
is recitation but it's like singing it's
similar it's similar to singing so music
you see when when something is delivered
way it's the only thing that doesn't go
through your intellect before it gets to
your soul it goes straight to your soul
see if you read a thing is going through
your intellect you're thinking about it
as you're reading it you know whereas
when you listen to it you're just
carried away and you're gone somewhere
else immediately do you know what I'm
saying so what I love is on YouTube they
have these and this is what I always
tell people on YouTube they have these
beautiful recitations where someone is
reciting it in Arabic and then someone
speaks the meaning of the paragraph in
in English you know I've been the one
that I use is called Journey Through the
Quran that's just him speaking that's
Journey Through the Quran but there's a
beautiful playlists where you can hear
it being recited and also
um spoken you know yeah so yeah that's
what I would advise it it has to be
listened to so we'll leave that some
advice from Sinead O'Connor to listen to
the Quran to pick it up at least listen
to it and and why not ask the Creator
who created the heavens and earth I'm
sure like you did alone for guided if
one is seeking person to want to know
purpose that's very straightforward and
simple yeah yeah very very nice thank
you so much Sinead O'Connor another
thing is uh before we cut out do you
find that because of the the Irish
people were were also uh there was at
one point in time you know being a
minority they were also uh there was a
lot of some negative press so do they
relate more with Muslims nowadays
knowing that you know Muslims are some
of the most oppressed people in the
world and some of this media hype that
Muslims are terrorists and all this
other you know uh hype that's this false
narrative that's being perpetuated they
can see through this yes absolutely
that's why people like me are are
reverting that's exactly we conceive
completely and utterly through it you
can see yeah of course we can because of
what's happened in our own church the
scandals the everything that's been
going on for the last 30 years 20 years
that people have been discovering the
the lies that we've been discovering
this horrible stink the horrible smell
of Oppression of the most vulnerable you
know and we've been watching what's been
happening
the world
policy we're not stupid people you know
I just came from and you can uh
inshallah God willing put it put it on
your to-do list to visit a Hidden Gem uh
I came from there and I'd like to say
that the uh there's a deep history in
Bosnia
and this is where my family's from and
when you study the history of how the
bosnians came to Islam they were
actually CR Unitarian the true
Christians who didn't believe Jesus was
God or a literal Son of God and they
also disconnected from the church and
they were considered Heretics but they
were just ones who just wanted to
worship like you like yourself they just
wanted to worship the one God and then
when Islam came submission to the will
of God Islam it fit like a glove they
accepted it and this is how Islam came
to to Bosnia yeah see that's right I'm
sorry go on no and this and this is why
we like to say that I make these uh
points because many times people think
this is something of the other it's
something far away but man we could say
look we were the original uh Christ
followers the ones who followed Christ
in pure monotheism well that's exactly
why Islam is so dangerous in averted
commas and to the world at worst its
money because as we said earlier on at
the beginning of this interview Islam is
the truth and has the truths you know
that's very very dangerous and then you
have an element of Islam that feels
understandably like it has nothing to
lose if you oppress people long enough
they're going to feel like I got nothing
to lose and there's nothing more
dangerous than somebody armed with the
truth who also feels they've got nothing
to lose you know thank you so much may
God Almighty the Creator Allah in
Aramaic the language Jesus spoke who we
love and reveal he would say Allah so
that's the same Creator and he would say
peace be unto you Shalom we say assalamu
alaikum you see what bridging those
those gaps educating the people so they
can say like wow like you did wow that
makes sense I want to check that out
yes thank you so much sister may Allah
continue to uh to bless you and keep you
preserve you and keep you safe thank you
so much for being on the D show now with
Sinead O'Connor brothers and sisters
again may God Almighty Allah have mercy
on her and Grant her gender there should
be a wake-up call for all of us
that this life is transitory it's very
short and it deaf can come at any time
so just like Sinead O'Connor being in a
position of ultimate Fame and stardom
and money and then finally towards the
end of her life she before dying a few
years back she accepted Islam
and now for the people out there who are
seeking to know the purpose of life and
what's this book that Sinead O'Connor
was talking about if you open your heart
open your mind and you beseech the
creator of heavens and earth for
guidance and then read the book read the
book we'll send you the book I'll send
you the book as a gift and if you have
any questions go ahead don't be shy tell
them Eddie sent you 1-800-662-islam
and that should be something that should
really shake people up death
what are you going to do with all that
money you accumulate at the end of the
day what are you going to do with all
those cars and you'll enjoy it for a
little bit of time then it gets played
out and then what happens with
everything you're going to leave it all
behind at the end of the day it's not
going to go with you but your belief
what you believed in any good that
you've done these are things that are
going to be transferable to the next but
then there's a paradise and if you work
for it just like if you work for that
paycheck you're working hard you put the
time in you put the effort and then you
get paid but if you don't show up to
work
if you don't obey your boss what's going
to happen you're going to get fired and
with God Almighty Allah if you don't
fulfill your responsibility roles and
obligations
that fire is the Hellfire so out of the
love we're trying to get people to
contemplate and think say people from
the Hell Fire get them to gender to
paradise and the roadmap for all of this
is in the Quran that's the book that
Sinead O'Connor was talking about
so contemplate and think the lights will
come on the party will end the buzz will
go away and then what do you got what
have you live for
70 80 90 years old if you make it to
that much and then what health issues
teeth falling out gray hair start
kicking in and what's it all for
what's it all for at the end but if you
fulfill your purpose and now when you
transition from this life and you go on
to the next as eternity brothers and
sisters eternity in Jannah in Jannah
this is based on proof and evidence it's
not blind faith and it's not an
irrational belief it's the belief of
worshiping one and only one God Almighty
alone worshiping the Creator not the
crazy and that's the foundation of Islam
and living a morally upright life learn
more go ahead and call if you have any
questions tell them I sent you don't be
shy 1-800-662 Islam
4752-1800-662-4752 and go to the
deanshow.com I will get you the free
copy of the Quran thank you very much
subscribe
if you haven't already hit that
notification Bell so you can get all the
upcoming shows and videos when they come
out
and until then peace be with you
assalamu alaikum
and I'm so excited to be here at the
dean Center mashallah which is under
renovation
see what's going to come inshallah
there's going to be a dawa Center
there's a Masjid there's a school in
Islamic school a gym and what we hope
inshallah will also have a mental health
part of this Center as well inshallah so
I'm asking you to please make sure that
you support this effort inshallah I
really hope that it spreads and really
the knowledge of Islam and people get to
know more about Muslims in Islam through
this effort
[Music]